il ne s'agit pas de mon patrimoine mais
de celui de mes enfants voilà ce
qu'indiqué aux médias d'un investigation
disclose votre ministre de la transition
énergétique selon cette enquête qui
révèle que les enfants d'Agnès panière
une hachée détiennent des parts dans une
société française dont les fonds sont en
partie domiciliés dans des paradis
fiscaux cette société a été créée par le
père de la ministre ancien dirigeant de
père and Co groupe pétrolier il y a donc
rien de dissimuler rien de cacher je
précise que je ne bénéficie pas et de
bénéficierez jamais de ces fonds n'ayant
aucun droit présent ou futur sur cette
société nous avions de la République qui
avait promis une République exemplaire
et que nous ne cessons pas d'avoir des
ministres qui sont mis en cause pour des
faits qui sont des faits
particulièrement graves et
particulièrement signifiant sur ce
qu'est la macronie jour de vote aux
États-Unis pour les élections de
mi-mandat il s'agit de renouveler
notamment la Chambre des représentants
un tiers du Sénat je ferai une très
grosse annonce mardi prochain
le 15 novembre
à Mara Lago Palm Beach
foncière à Paris va augmenter de 52%
2023 la décision hier soir de la mère de
la capitale anidalgo qui renie une
promesse de campagne pour faire face à
l'inflation des prix de l'énergie on
augmente pas les taxes et les impôts à
ce niveau-là au détour d'un petit tweet
et de manière planquée Paris n'est pas
la seule à augmenter ses impôts locaux
4,7% de hausse en moyenne sur les 200
plus grandes villes du pays 14 voient la
facture s'envoler de plus de 10% record
à poids si 23,9% de hausse 16% à
Marseille et à Tours en 2001 quel est le
niveau de la dette à Paris il est d'un
milliard d'euros sous les mandats de
Anne Hidalgo la dette atteint
aujourd'hui 10 milliards d'euros on nous
amène encore une inflation qui
contrairement à ce qui est dit
n'est pas que passagère l'inflation qui
se prépare avec les nouvelles
négociations là autour de Noël cette
inflation elle est à deux chiffres EOS
sont-elles suspectes elles sont en tout
cas de plus en plus
les produits alimentaires ont pris en un
an en moyenne 11,8% d'après le dernier
indice INSEE de la fin octobre c'est
sans précédent depuis 40 ans ce qu'a
subi Grégoire de Fornas c'est une
véritable manipulation qui ne visait pas
tant lui d'ailleurs que le rassemblement
national dans son ensemble
le bureau de l'Assemblée à choisir une
sanction extrêmement lourde pour en
réalité des faits dont on dont ils ont
eux-mêmes constaté qu'il n'avaient rien
à voir avec le racisme c'était un procès
stalinien
c'est encore un chèque
mais vous avez participé à ce procès
faible et vous êtes tous levés comme un
seul homme lAssemblée nationale vous
allez parce que quand je vois une
députée dimanche tu es mort je n'ai pas
ressenti que ça avait suscité une
indignation majeure alors moi voyez-vous
ce genre de déclaration made in aussi de
ce lieu réinvesti par les migrants le
boulevard de la Chapelle à Paris un
petit tour est plus revient les tentes
ont à nouveau fleuri sous le métro
aérien parisien les républicains vous
creusez votre tombe
vous nous dit ça sur chaque plateau donc
vous étiez à 4 % la dernière fois vous
allez être à deux hein fréquentable
Jordan Bardella
je crois qu'il a il a jamais il a jamais
des il a jamais dérapé après on a des
convictions des positionnements qui sont
naturellement des différents vous ne
pouvons plus accueillir toute la misère
du monde et je pense que cette image est
absolument désolante accueillir des gens
pour les entasser à des portes de
périphériques ou sur des ports français
est une image qui ne me convient pas
Jordan Bardella il a parlé tout Jordan
je pense que vous êtes plus proche de
Jordan
de la ligne sociale du rassemblement
national c'est moi
d'accord c'est moi c'est ma ligne je la
défends depuis 2002 et par conséquent il
y a pas plus attaché à ce que cette
ligne
perdure que moi-même oui mais pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas avec lui vous êtes plus
proche de vous mais pourquoi il est pas
avec nous moi je lui ai dit qu'est-ce
que